c'est un événement mondial suivie par
plus de 700 millions de personnes la 41e
édition de la ryder cup s'est tenu du 30
septembre au 2 octobre à chaska dans le
minnesota
les meilleurs golfeurs de la planète
étaient présents sur les greens on
pouvait apercevoir l'icône américaine
tiger woods son camp le nord irlandais
rory mcilroy
le spectacle était également dans les
tribunes trois cent mille personnes ont
créé une ambiance digne d'un match de
football pendant la compétition
il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont déguisés
déguisé on voit beaucoup d'américains
mais on voit aussi des déguisements
européens ce qui est sympa à voir
également
c'est une pure atmosphère nous ne
pouvons pas la comparer à une ambiance
classique l'ambiance est comparable à un
stade de football
cauvin c'est la plus grande compétition
le pays la prend très au sérieux et nous
sommes très fiers de cette victoire de
l'indépendant dean baker la ryder cup
capte également l'attention des médias
mille cinq cents journalistes venus du
monde entier ont été accrédités pour
assister à la compétition
je suis ici pour sky sports je m'occupe
des médias sociaux facebook twitter
instagram et je couvre ce qu'il se passe
en dehors de la compétition pour les
fans de la ryder cup
je suis reporter pour une chaîne de golf
en chine c'est ma première expérience
sur une ryder cup et je suis très excité
d'être ici et tout miser sur le plan
économique plus de 150 millions de
dollars sont engrangés sur le site
pendant les trois jours de compétition
selon les chiffres donnés par les
organisateurs les visiteurs ont consommé
en moyenne entre 5 et 10 litres de
boissons sur cette ryder cup
le panier moyen d'un américain serait
lui 200 $ dans les boutiques du site un
impact économique conséquent qui devrait
également se ressentir à saint quentin
en yvelines
d'après les études que nous avons
réalisées en impacts directs liés à
l'événement on aurait à peu près 150
millions de création de richesses et en
indirect qu'il faut rajouter à peu près
50% donc un total de 225 millions
d'euros
de création de richesses sur un
événement qui est un événement assez
court puisque c'est trois jours de
compétition c'est très important
la ryder cup sera organisé en france du
28 au 30 septembre plus de 60000
personnes devraient venir chaque jour au
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines pour assister à cette
compétition mythique